so this story is going to have one of
the most amazing endings ever so make
sure you guys stick around for that but
uh I kind of forgot that DC was doing
deceased
not gonna lie I'm a little bit ashamed
uh I gotta get caught up you know what I
mean so here's the thing uh picking back
up with this right we come off issues
one and two make sure you guys check the
playlist down in the description so you
can get caught up we're literally two
issues in so we're just kind of picking
up with issues three and four in this
video so you don't have a whole lot of
catching up to do but what this does is
this initially focuses on a guy by the
name of Adam Strange now Adam Strange is
a cool character and he's a guy that you
don't really see a whole lot of Stories
being done with but he's got one of the
most interesting aspects to any
character in DC Comics so check this out
the idea behind Adam Strange and he's an
old Julia Schwartz character from back
in the 1950s the idea behind Adam
Strange is that on the planet ran right
you basically had the Emperor who did
what's the equivalent of like shining a
flashlight from half a mile away in the
middle of the desert right like you'd
see that light and just be like what's
that right and you would go and see what
it was so the idea behind the people of
ran is they literally sent a Zeta beam
down to earth and the whole hopes that
like people on Earth would be like what
in the world is this they would trace it
back to its source and they would come
into contact with an extraterrestrial
race right expand the possibilities of
humanity what ended up happening is the
Zeta beam was mutated through Cosmic
radiation so when it hit Adam Strange it
basically gave him powers and then it
teleported him to the planet of ran
where he basically ended up falling in
love with his chick named Alana right
he's actually got a child right so they
they basically have a kid together but
the idea behind the Zeta beam is that
there is no real controlling it right
like Adam Strange would be teleported to
ran and then he'll be there for a little
while then the Zeta beam will randomly
teleport him back there's no way of
knowing when that's going to happen so
the idea behind his character is that he
would literally just run around Earth
trying to find where the new Zeta beam
was going to arrive and then ride the
beam back to ran where he would offer a
really kind of operate as a protector of
the planet while also trying to be with
his love interest it was cool right it
was really really cool DC never really
knew what to do with him but the story
behind him was great and that's really
what happens here right ran is one of
the worlds that is under attack at the
hands of basically the undead Armada
right if you guys remember everything we
covered in the first two issues of War
of the undead gods that dark side has
now re-emerged infected with the
anti-life equation right basically this
kind of anti-life version of like a
zombie virus not only that darkseid's
also a Yellow Lantern now right so it's
a immensely powerful dark side more so
than he normally is and this literally
allowed all these zombies that have
basically been moving around the
universe and infecting worlds to
coalesce under the power of Darkseid and
then start moving forward with an
intention right to literally start
conquering world after world after world
and so where Adam Strange is teleported
away his wife and his kid are basically
left there to fend for themselves as
best they can along with whatever
survivors are there now it's not
something that takes them by surprise
again Alana is well familiar with this
his kids well familiar with this right
they're aware it's just how these things
go and ironic enough one of the downside
of his character is that these things
that the Zeta beam would always activate
at the most inconvenient time right so
literally this is the worst time for the
beam to activate but when it does it
teleports him back down to earth and he
arrives in Gotham City two months before
a cure is found for the anti-life virus
and so what ends up happening is that as
he's making his way through Gotham he
sees Wonder Woman while he's trying to
understand what had happened here once
he sees Wonder Woman of course she was
infected this is of course before she
died but she was infected she
immediately attacks Adam Strange and
turns Adam Strange into one of the
zombies so what ends up happening is
about two weeks later Adam Strange is
teleported back to ran using a Zeta beam
and when he arrives he's infected and
then attacks his family so it's just the
craziest thing right it's absolutely
Bonkers now a few days after that we
basically transition over to the rilex
system with one of the coolest moments
right one of the absolute best moments
in this it's not the crazy ending that
I'm was telling you about but it is one
of the coolest moments right so
basically here in this bar and when you
guys you guys know when we're talking
about a bar out in space in DC Comics
you know who we're talking about we're
talking about the main man Lobo himself
that's right ladies and gentlemen now
anybody out there who's not familiar
with Lobo this guy was designed back in
the day to be like an over-the-top
version of Wolverine from Marvel Comics
that basically was on par with the power
of Superman Lobo is a hoss right this
guy is amazing but the thing about this
is this guy kind of shows up out of
nowhere and says like I'm looking for
somebody Noble who can basically you
know help thin the universe against
whatever threat is out there right this
massive threat that's kind of running
around we're looking for somebody to
help us uh is anybody down right is
anybody you know interested in this now
of course lobo's like what does it pay
and this guy is like I am looking for
someone Noble you clearly do not fit
that description now the problem here is
everybody hears this said and it's just
kind of like bruh
that ain't what you want to say to a man
like Lobo
right but the crazy thing about this is
before Lobo can help this guy finish
with all his living we end up having a
thanagerian warship that arrives onto
the scene and as this warship emerges of
course all these thanagarians who had
basically been taken over by the
anti-life virus basically the race where
like Hawkman and hot girl come from that
they literally start like pouring into
the entirety of the bar and even the
planet as a whole and start attacking
everybody now the funny thing about this
is one of these guys attacks Lobo and
they scratch him now under normal
circumstances a person would change Lobo
does not because Lobo has an insane
healing Factor he can heal from pretty
much anything in fact the Lobo has been
cut into pieces and then just
reconstituted himself again he is his
level of just strength and durability
and healing factor is designed to be
ridiculously over the top in comical in
this story it pays off because this
guy's like this guy's like you do not
turn and Lobo is like oh I could turn
right I can keep turning and turning
until your head comes off your shoulders
and like rips his head off
and he's like nobody starts killing
Lobos bartenders without Lobo doing
anything about it so Lobo literally
shows up here and annihilates the
entirety of not only the thanagerian
worship but most of the thanagarians
themselves and that's where this guy is
like okay so like I guess you are the
warrior I was looking for right a guy
who's really capable I mean he got
problems right but we could use you
right I mean you know it's it's we can
make it work you know what I mean we can
make it work right so literally what we
do here is we switch over to the mascara
now again the mascara is throwing a
funeral for Wonder Woman now it's one of
those things that's really cool here
because of course Diana was turned by
the virus and then literally was
instrumental in slaughtering I don't
know how many people on Earth but the
thing about this is before all of that
she was Diana right like the princess of
the mascara Wonder Woman and Amazon so
it's one of those things where just
because she was was turned by a virus
and led to the wholesale Slaughter
pretty much all with Humanity doesn't
make her a bad guy right we all make
mistakes right we all make mistakes we
all do things that we don't mean to do
and sometimes we say things we don't
mean to say but in all seriousness right
Wonder Woman has always been an
exceedingly honorable member of the
superhero community and because of that
her people on the mascara she's a sister
to them so it's less that Wonder Woman
what on this Rampage is some kind of a
villain and more that she was a victim
of a circumstance that she couldn't
control and so with this this funeral
being uh held for her what you end up
having is of course Artemis and Oliver
Queen now Artemis she's a little more
interesting this is really
um I would say Tom Taylor building on
what's been happening with DC Comics
over the last few years as far as
Artemis goes that the idea behind her
character is that she was an Amazon that
ultimately ended up making her way out
into the larger superhero Community not
really in an identical way to Wonder
Woman and of course she fought alongside
Red Hood in the Outlaws which was an
amazing comic in DC rebirth oh my God
Red Hood oh you guys remember that red
hood in the Outlaws from DC rebirth dude
that story was amazing DC is absolutely
jumped the shark in recent years but
back when DC rebirth let's go dude
everything was the best thing coming out
of DC rebirth I'm just saying like the
stories were absolutely amazing but of
course they basically fire off the Euros
to you know it's kind of a funeral pyre
for for Wonder Woman and that's when
Aries the God of War shows up now under
normal circumstances when Aries shows up
it's because he's looking to start some
stuff right kind of stir that pot a
little bit get conflict ruined by
feeding off the conflicts of people
inciting them into war with each other
different things like that but the thing
about this is that with his arrival the
themiscarians absolutely like
immediately turn on him right the
Amazon's like turn on this guy and
they're like you're not welcome here you
don't need to be here but of course he
tells him like I am not here to be your
enemy I'm not here to incite conflict or
to incite war and yes myself and Wonder
Woman were massive enemies over the year
years but one I'm here to pay my
respects to an honorable Warrior and two
I basically am enlisting you guys in a
gigantic conflict that's going on I will
show you what's happening and so what he
does is he brings all of them to the
Hall of the Gods and of course he
basically ends up giving the arrow of
Apollo to Oliver Queen right to Green
Arrow which is cool right because he
basically gets the bow of a God now of
course he says the weight feels a little
off can I tweak it and the response of
Aries is just like can you tweak the
golden bow of Apollo a bow that hunted
the great beasts of of cocoon whatever
uh that slew the Leviathan lion and he
and Oliver's like yeah man it's a little
top heavy and he's like fine you know
you can tweak it so one of the things I
love about Tom Taylor writing is he kind
of has the ability to sort of inject
humor with characters that you wouldn't
normally expect to be humorous Ares is
never really a humorous guy right he's
never really the guy where like he jokes
and you know and makes little comments
and stuff but it's more the context of
the situation that makes the whole thing
funny but the reality is that that's
when when they ask Aries what is it that
you want from us right like why did you
bring us here and so what Aries says is
there's a war coming right now of course
Cassie sandsmark who was at one point
Wonder Woman literally says like we just
had a war now now you're here billions
died before this and this is where
things get crazy because what Aries says
is that was no war there was no struggle
there was only defeat I am not the god
of Slaughter and that's an important
distinction to understand here right
when you look at the entirety of
deceased it is kind of easy to look at
that and it's like it's a war of the the
survivors versus the ones who are
infected but that's not how it played
out remember back in like the first DC
story what happened people got infected
and the world ended like over the course
of the first like the original story arc
the original DC story arc that happened
if I remember over the course of like a
few days like maybe a week or two but
the world collapsed almost immediately
it was literally just people being
infected and the superheroes fleeing for
their lives because the infection had
spread so incredibly fast really thanks
to the flash you've been infected that
there was nothing anybody could do right
so the superheroes were just trying to
save who they could where they could and
got out as fast as they can right there
was no war it was just people fleeing
for their lives and so that's literally
what he's saying now and of course what
is kind of nuts that he says that it's
not just a war that's coming but it's a
war that cannot be won the final war
right it will be glorious but ultimately
futile I will stay to watch the end but
every race in the universe will die and
so when the questions asked how can you
be so certain of our failure and he says
because all of this has happened before
and that's what's so cool about this
right this it's literally Battlestar
Galactica all of this has happened
before and all of it will happen again
he says this is how the entire universe
was infected and so where Oliver asked
the question like Aries presents a book
to him right and says this is how things
unfolded before the response of Oliver
Queen is the most logical one where he's
like okay so if what you're holding is a
record book right a book that says like
this is how things transpired before
somebody had to have survived to tell
the tale which means if there was one
Survivor there was more than one
Survivor otherwise every race would have
just died out for no other reason than
the fact that they can't procreate
anymore right so that means if there
were survivors then the question has to
be asked how did we survive this last
time and the response of Aries is no one
did this is a record from a universe
that was lost right a universe that was
completely and totally lost and so at
that moment you basically have Dinah
who's basically the green Canary right
she got a Green Lantern ring that she's
contacted by the Guardians of the
universe who were just like we're
calling every single Green Lantern
Across the Universe back to OHA we're
forming a staging ground right we're
going to use owa as a Battleground to
figure out how we can defeat all these
different Undead folks who are out there
and that's when that's when Aries says
it begins right and so literally this
goes out to everyone out there right
Kyle Raynor Jon Stewart like kilowog the
whole nine yards Guy Gardner who's out
there every single Green Lantern not
only that the response of the Guardians
on OA is like bring everybody who is an
ally everybody who's alive any
able-bodied man and woman who can fight
that has any measure of power bring them
to owa right every super-powered being
in the universe is coming here if we can
find some way to Stage to you know keep
this conflict from spreading beyond what
it already is but the funny thing here
is kind of jumping back to Aries the
response of Oliver Queen is well things
are different now when the whole event
first kicked off we had no idea what was
going on but now we have a cure we have
the ability to cure everybody like
Oliver's stance is like we've basically
already won the only issue that we have
now is how do we get a cure to everybody
out there in order to turn them back to
normal and the response of Aries is
you're not fighting an equation right
and that's when when like Donna or I'm
sorry Cassie Chimes and it says yeah but
Dark Side set and Aries response is dark
side is a new God he's a child right a
powerful Pawn for something much larger
he had had no idea what he was doing
when he merged the anti-life equation
with death the Gaze has been turned
towards us that's the real threat he
says this is no equation this is older
than numbers older than the gods the
universe will die and he says
erebos is here right so Erebus is this
being that's basically behind all of
this right this is the force that was
Unleashed now from here we switch over
to one of the coolest parts of the story
right one of the coolest parts of this
that what ends up happening here is
Alfred initially has these Visions where
if you recall in the first DC story he
was forced to kill Batman and Tim Drake
and Dick Grayson he was forced to kill
these guys so the only person that was
really left here was basically Damien
Wayne now if I recall correctly I don't
remember off the top of my head I want
to say that red hood survived but I
can't remember I know he was part of one
of the tie-in stories so if you guys
recall down in the comments section let
me know I could look it up but like I'm
in the middle of recording this right
now also you know I'm I'm a single task
person I don't do very well when it
comes to multitasking but of course all
these visions and everything kind of
wake Alfred up out of his sleep and
these basically they're accompanied by
Leslie Tompkins now Leslie Tompkins had
for the longest time been an ally of
Batman she was kind of comparable to
Night Nurse from Marvel Comics she is
much older than that but or at least
have been around longer than that but
the idea behind Leslie is she was the
one that would tend to the wounds of
Batman if he needed it or she would help
other members of the superhero Community
depending on the circumstance she was a
very significant character in the Batman
Mythos over the years she lost that
level of importance in DC Comics and
it's just kind of been relegated to a
background character so one of the cool
things about Tom Taylor's run is that he
has sort of bolstered her presence back
up to being a significant member of the
bat family even if it's only here to be
a love interest and somebody to comfort
Alfred but the thing about this is that
when Damien and Jonathan tell Alfred
they have to leave that they have to go
join the Guardians of the Galaxy and I'm
sorry the Guardians of the universe in
order to deal with this massive threat
of the dead Armada that initially Alfred
begs Damien not to go right he's like
please don't leave I already lost your
father I already lost what were
basically my sons I don't want to lose
another son again but the reality of
Damien and this really shows how much
he's changed since like the initial
outbreak happened and how he's really
become a hero that's stepping into this
role his response to Alfred is this is
much bigger than me right it's much
bigger than you this is literally the
fate of the universe and if I can die in
order to save the universe then it's a
death worth having I don't want to I'm
not going into this with the expectation
that I die but if I do it will be for a
great cause and so the response of
Alfred and this is incredibly important
here because I have a theory about this
I don't know if it's actually happened
yet but I have a theory about this the
response of Alfred is if I can't get you
to stay here then I want to fight
alongside all of you right I want to
fight alongside you guys in defeating
these Undead Gods they've taken so much
from me and I don't want to sit on the
sidelines and basically do nothing and
the response of of Damien is you really
want to fight against these guys and the
response of Alfred is yes you have to
find a way a weapon a power a ring and
whatever it is I want to fight I don't
want to sit uselessly on the sidelines
now of course this leads to Damien and
Jonathan taking their leave and
ultimately going but it's really not
without Damien saying like you say that
there's so much of my father and me I
say there's a lot of my father in you
because he would he would he would say
the same thing right if he were in your
position he would say like I don't want
to sit on the sidelines if for whatever
reason Bruce Wayne was incapable of
operating his Batman say he was
wheelchair-bound or something like that
and didn't have a suit that could
compensate by giving him the ability to
move that he would simply say like I
want I want to do something I want to be
able to fight in some capacity or maybe
Batman's like 90 years old like he is in
Batman Beyond right he's like a million
years old and just grizzled and just
this crotchety old son of a gun bat cave
but still you know it's one of those
things because my theory here is that
Alfred is going to become a Green
Lantern I don't know if that's going to
happen in but I think Alfred's gonna be
a Green Lantern and the reason why I say
that is if you guys remember Tom
Taylor's Injustice Alfred took a pill
that gave him the powers of Superman and
beat the crap out of Superman and
rescued Batman from almost being killed
by Superman and then took Batman out of
the bat cave and just left Superman
there but Tom Taylor has a way of always
like giving Alfred some kind of power
right giving Alfred some kind of an
ability at this point we switch over to
almarak now I'm gonna be honest with you
guys man we're basically shown Maxima
right now here's the thing anybody who's
been reading DC Comics for any measure
of time probably had the same response
that I did where you're like maximum she
hasn't been relevant since like the days
when Superman died which is true so the
idea behind Maxima and it's one of the
most crazy things the idea behind Maxima
is that DC was tired of the idea of like
Batman I'm sorry uh almost said Batman a
Superman they were tired of the idea of
like uh of Superman and Lois Lane and so
the idea of Maxima is that their her and
Superman were genetically compatible and
so what that meant is that she could
give Superman like the perfect kids
right Superman didn't want to marry her
and didn't want to have any kids with
her so he ultimately rejected her but it
was an attempt by by DC Comics to create
a new love interest for superman but the
thing about this is that uh she hasn't
been relevant since she appeared in a
couple different Comics here and there
but like literally no one cared right
this is spelling oh cool maximum
whatever man and just keep turning the
page so it is interesting to see her
here but much like her complete and
total level of irrelevance in DC Comics
she's also irrelevant here because her
planet is attacked by dark side and the
undead Armada and they're all conquered
and that's the story of her so of course
what we end up doing here is jumping
back to OHA and like the coming together
of all the Guardians of the universe as
well as all the superheroes who are here
now the now everybody like all the
superpower survivors or any able-bodied
person who can fight this is numbered
potentially in the billions right just
this massive crowd being addressed by
the Guardians and what they say is that
the undead Armada has already taken 12
planets right these 12 planets have been
seized completely and totally raised and
their their occupants or their races
converted into members of the undead and
it's just spreading like a plague right
their numbers are growing at an
exponential rate one person bites two
those two by four those four by eight
those eight by sixteen you understand
what I'm saying like it's just moving
and it's just moving so fast and
spreading across the universe so quickly
that the response to the Guardians is
there's only one thing we can do here
right like another seven planets with
species clearly seen by as assets by the
anti-life equation have been infected so
now we're at 19 and he says we are
sanctioning lethal Force these infected
worlds have to be wiped away now this is
an important distinction because
traditionally the Green Lanterns are
peacekeeping Force One of the rules that
was laid down when it came to the
Guardians of the universe is the Green
Lanterns could not take lies in more
recent years in DC Comics that changed
during Jeff John's run on Green Lantern
with the Sinestro core War it was one of
the massive moments of the conflict
because like the Sinestro core the
yellow lanterns are just like wiping out
Green Lanterns everywhere they find them
because Sinestro knows like the Green
Lanterns can't harm anybody in that way
they can't end the life and so literally
in the middle of this battle the
Guardians are like we have no choice and
all these Green Lantern rings start
lighting up with a statement lethal
force is now sanctioned and like the
tide turns like that like it's just it's
nuts the Green Lanterns are like it's
all like Donkey Kong and they just start
they start taking it to the to the the
celestial core God that story is so good
it was so phenomenal but the thing about
this is that in response to this of
course Superman who's now cured of the
anti-life virus and his son Jonathan do
exactly what you would expect him to
which is say we can't wipe out these
worlds we have a cure we should be
focusing on how to cure these people in
terms of wiping these people out now
there are moral arguments on both sides
and reasonable arguments on both sides
The Stance of Superman and Jonathan is
the preservation of Life helping people
as opposed to ending people but Brainiac
and these guys who are survivors and
have Allied themselves against the
anti-life virus their response is the
the possible risk of going to the
anti-life Armada and trying to inject
people with a cure the risk is too great
because all that would have to happen is
Jonathan Kent or Superman or some other
being out there with Incredible levels
of power or Brainiac with his incredible
intellect all they all will happen is
they're turned and it's game over right
like The Dominoes fall and it's the end
of everything the risk is too great The
only thing that we can really do in
order to bring this thing to an end is
to eradic hate everybody there so it's a
it's it's there's reasonable arguments
on both sides right sometimes the risk
of the Cure is worse than the disease so
you just wipe out the disease which also
includes wiping people out so it's one
of those weird situations where you can
kind of create arguments on both sides
but of course one ends up happening is
Superman responds kind of
uncharacteristically by lashing out and
in fact attacking ganthe right just like
punching this guy right just like
knocking this guy out because literally
ganthin is just like if you stand
against us and everybody else who's
joined you we will destroy you like
we'll lock you up in a prison that'll be
the end of it and we will go and take
out these worlds and so Superman
attacking gamthet is not something that
you normally see and so it's kind of
weird because while all this is
happening we end up finding out Aries is
basically watching all of this unfold
and what's so interesting about this is
that it's actually Damien Wayne who
picks up on what's Happening he's
looking around at this whole situation
and how quickly everybody went crazy and
all started attacking each other and his
response is something is wrong right
like I can feel it my pulse is elevated
my judgment's clouded my emotional
response is heightened we are not in
control of this situation and that's
when he sees Aries and realizes Aries is
kind of goading them all into fighting
each other because Aries is the god of
war and and is just kind of into that
cool stuff now of course literally
Damien says like you're manipulating us
God of War and the response of Aries is
I just gave you all A little nudge
Damien says stop this and then a voice
comes out of nowhere and says you should
listen to that little man Aries this
voice is coming from Mr mixopitalic he
says I won't let you hurt Superman the
fifth dimensional imp where the power of
a God is here Mr mixopitalic this guy
can alter reality on a whim so the real
question you have to ask here is what
would happen in deceased if Mr
mixopitalic is converted to an undead
God what would happen there because all
he has to do is Alter reality and it's
the end of everything but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace